>>Steven: Elk Grove Unified School
District is the fifth largest school
district in the state of California.
We serve approximately
62,000 students.
We cover 320 square
miles, which is one-third
of the entire county of Sacramento.
We have a very richly
diverse population,
with over 80 languages being
spoken inside the district.
When I first started my
career, I was a shop teacher,
and so one of the things that I
will share is that when we talk
about career technical education in
the 21st century, those woodshops
of the past is not what career
technical education is about today.
For the 21st century,
we have young people
in the Elk Grove Unified School
District that are harvesting algae
so that they can press
out of the algae oils
so that they can make biofuels.
And we're seeing teachers
at a variety of our schools
that are getting students not only
engaged in the academic rigors
of a multiple-pathway career
technical education program
but are getting them engaged in ways
that their academics
are very rigorous,
that they're taking the kinds
of higher mathematics
that you want to see.
And so I would suggest that
it's green academy, animation,
agriculture that is allowing our
students to be very productive,
both academically and being well
prepared to go into higher education
and then go into the workforce
because the skill sets
that they're getting
really are 21st century.
We are seeing our students
with higher attendance
rates in our academies.
There is a very, very
high success rate
of students not only
completing the program
but going on to higher education.
We're seeing students
that are highly motivated,
and there are several
reasons for these things--
obviously, the connection
with the instructors,
connection with the family, kind of
a feel inside the academy programs,
the peer support for one another,
so we're seeing all of those.
Now, we're also watching our
young people do very well
on the California High
School Exit Exam.
We are seeing success
in the programs.
We are seeing success in graduation.
We're seeing success in kids going
on into higher education
and the world of work.
>>Instructor: Again, and just
a little more theatricality.
>>Steven: Our academies
are not exclusive.
They are inclusive.
California Partnership Academies
ask for at least 40% of the students
to come into the program that
would be, in some people's eyes,
considered at-risk students.
Now, our doors are open.
We want to see, as does the
California Partnership Academy,
that there is dedicated staff that
work with a collection of students
on an integrated fashion to ensure
that the delivery of the work,
all the way from the
keystone class all the way
through the academic rigor coming
through the program, is integrated,
that is focused, that
there is clear evidence
of where those relationships emerge.
And if you have a particular--
let's take culinary arts.
So that in the science
aspect of culinary arts,
we want to see the science that
really is not only good science
but how does it relate to culinary
production or food production.
We were one of the first districts
in the state of California actually
to use a modified national rubric to
certify academies, and quite frankly,
we wanted to make sure that if
you said you were an academy,
that the criteria that
we wanted to see in place
as the Elk Grove Unified School
District and that the gold seal
that you would get would be
reflective of a true academy
and that we didn't want
to be confused about that.
We didn't want to have a collection
of electives be categorized
as an academy, so we
put that in place.
>>Teacher: This is a closed-loop
photo bioreactor, and it's designed
to be able to grow algae.
And what we want to do then is to be
able to take that algae and turn it
into products like fuel or...
Stephen: Part of the Academy and
certification is tremendous outreach,
and that is a valuable,
necessary ingredient to academies
and the pathways to have business
partnerships that are there not just
for money, because money is
certainly helpful and important,
but it's that technical view
of what is your trade looking
for in young people going into
college and then into work
or going directly into the workforce.
What we need to do is
quit talking about this
as being an either or,
college or careers.
This is about making sure that the
young people of today in California
and across the country are prepared
to go on to higher education,
go into the world of work and be
successful, and be contributors
in a global economy, that our
students have a quality of life
that anchors them to
be productive citizens.
>>Narrator: For more
information about what works
in education, go to Edutopia.org.